d'amélie nothomb bonsoir alors vous
n'avez pas froid la non tout va bien
c'est quand vous écrivez vous crever de
froid vous gardez vos mitaines c'est pas
parce que vous avez froid c'est le
porte-jarretelles de la main h le
porte-jarretelles de la main très bien
ça commence fort alors il ya plein de
plein de trucs en promo là il ya le
sabotage amoureux donc été un roman est
publié en 93 qui est remonté sur scène
au théâtre du ranelagh
adapté par annabelle milot et pascal
lissy lourd avec valérie mairesse alors
valérie mairesse vous l'avez connu quand
quand vous êtes allé chez laurent
ruquier en effet ce mois de septembre
pour l'apparition de mercure j'ai
rencontré valérie mairesse qui m'a dit
tiens je suis en train d'étudier votre
texte parce qu'on monte la pièce
sabotage amoureux moi je suis tombé des
nues première nouvelle je n'en savais
rien pour vous dire à quel point je n'y
suis pour rien oui bah d'ailleurs alors
vous l'avez vu hier soir pour la
première fois j'étais vierge jusqu'à
hier soir et alors ses sensations et
c'est vrai vous êtes contents non
sérieusement je m'attendais au pire
sincèrement pour moi il n'avait aucune
chance de réussir c'est un livre qui
n'avait aucune chance d'être adapté au
théâtre c'est de la narration c'est
surréaliste on sait nous a dit non en
gros l'argument du livre c'est un
souvenir d'enfance ça se passe à pékin
de 72 à 75 c'est une guerre enfantine et
est le récit d'un premier amour avec la
petite italienne c'est serena oui c'est
ça scéniquement jeu ça me paraissait
promis au désastre mais la mise en scène
est tellement incroyablement ingénieuse
que c'est fabuleux tout le monde est et
pousse vous êtes contente suite c'est au
théâtre durera au théâtre du ranelagh
donc pas y aller un seuil et la
maintenance et c'est sur scène c'est
parti et que notre amie valérie mairesse
voilà alors ça c'est la pièce oui après
il ya le film dans le film est tiré de
votre premier roman qui s'appelait
hygiène de l'assassin donc été en 92 et
nous on a faim on avait reçus ici jean
claude dreyfus qui était qui était venu
parler on est est allé voir la pièce à
l'époque donc là c'est un film qui a été
fait par françois ruggeri oui avec jean
yanne c'est ça oui ça n'a absolument
rien à voir avec la pièce jouée par
dreyfus qui ont passé c'est encore tout
à fait autre chose ici on peut le dire
on est assez loin du roman de dub avoue
d'ailleurs dire il ya écrit librement
trahi j'ai créé pour les besoins de la
cause une nouvelle formule juridique
j'avais l'intention de bien m'entendre
avec françois ruggeri qui est l'homme le
plus charmant du monde son scénario
vraiment de poser de problème parce que
l'europe le lien de parents avec mon
livre est très floue mais vraiment très
flou et alors je lui ai dit écoute si tu
veux qu'on s'entende bien j'exige que tu
crées pour moi une nouvelle formule
juridique qui figurera aussi bien sur le
contrat que sur le roman très librement
trahi de à la place de vous comment
adapter 2 je me demande si la formule
fera ici c'est bien bah ça c'est aussi
cela fera école parce que c'est
généralement le cas alors il ya jean
yanne ya barbara schulz qu'on voit dans
les portes du ciel de jacques attali
avec depardieu en ce moment sur scène
alors on dit tout l'argument enfin
m'avait beaucoup parlé avec dreyfus ici
mais dit tout quoi il retourne quoi
c'est ce vieux prix nobel c'est un vieux
prix nobel de littérature mourant il n'a
plus que pour deux mois à vivre et il
décide comme dernier divertissement de
s'offrir une journaliste a démoli comme
passe temps seulement il tombe sur une
dure à cuire qui est la petite barbara
schulz qui est des matantes et ça m'a
donné une joute verbale voile alors
troisième chose vous mais pas pour rien
quand vous venez vous troisième chose
ils livrent donc mercure qui est sorti
en septembre qui marche très très bien
oui oui nous en dire un mot comme ça
pour eux très difficile d'en parler
parce que c'est un livre qui est
entièrement par du construit à partir
d'une imposture verbale
c'est un trucage pour la première fois
j'ai vraiment écrit avec un trucage du
coup si j'en parle de trucage ses
fondations ils achèteront l'ia c'est
chez albin michel voilà alors battu lyon
1 alors vous êtes un personnage étonnant
vous avez fait irruption dans l'est dans
les médias français il ya sept ans
maintenant six ans si l'on rêverait oui
c'est ça et vous êtes effectivement
tailler une place parce que vous êtes un
personnage très particulier d'abord vous
venez d'une famille qui en france on
connaît pas bien mais en belgique la
famille nos tombes c'est quelque chose
c'est ça qui est merveilleux c'est être
publiés en france les trois quarts des
français me demande pourquoi j'ai choisi
ce pseudonyme étrangers pas combien
leurs questions et les fratries
finissante parce que c'est vrai qu'en
belgique celle connue bien sûr cela il
ya en 1830 au moment de la création de
la belgique le type qui a écrit la
constitution s'appelait notamment celle
du mans c'est à dire que la la
la belgique résulte de la coalition de
bill famille on peut dire qu'ils chacune
ont apporté une partie de leur
territoire de l'extrême sud est de la
belgique a été apportée par les notes en
voilà c'est affreusement lourd à porter
alors vous aviez vous aviez annoncé
votre arrière grand père s'appelait
pierre oui alors qu'ils étaient un
personnage intéressant qui est un poète
chrétien qui avait fondé l'action
nationale qu'un peu comparable à
l'action française vous pouvez imaginer
comme ce nom est tu rapportés mais il
paraît qu'on est arrivé à l'université
les gens vont regarder avec un air un
peu consterné d'autant plus que moi je
n'étais au courant de rien oui vie que
je signais en extrême-orient j'ai grandi
wissem orient et mes parents avaient eu
le bon goût de ne rien je dis pas ça
voulait dire mais c'est parce qu'il
était quoi absolument pas je suis arrivé
pour la première fois en europe à 17 ans
à bruxelles pour aller à l'université
san mamés dites moi il a rien fait de
mal quand même si il n'a rien fait de
mal non il était ce qu'il était rexiste
il l'a probablement était maintenant en
même temps non parce qu'il était
beaucoup trop chrétiens pour ça oui
l'érection gare donc c'est des gens
quelque chose parti de lyon de grêle
saint jean a posé sa main droite un peu
cool ça non il a il a dit beaucoup de
choses il a écrit beaucoup de choses n'a
rien fait il voulait lui voulait faire
la grande belgique ans assez rigolo
d'avoir un projet de deux ans c'est plus
grave que ça il voulait créer un empire
catholiques d'europe dont il se serait
bien venu parce qu'il était assez mégalo
qui serait allée de la flandre à venise
ah oui avait d'accord et c'est là la
lotharingie de l'exacte angleterre fils
fils de charles onana dois je préciser
que je me désole désolidarise totalement
de tous ses points de vue bien sûr non
pas bon en même temps c'est votre grand
père quoi je n'ai jamais connu je suis
né en 67 jouaient ce qu'il ya plein de
gens aujourd'hui au gouvernement quand
il des parents collaborateurs et voilà
ils sont socialistes mais pas de
problème le vous l'avez lu son bouquin
le prince de old time non j'ai lu l'un
de ses livres ne serait ce que pour ce
livre là je ne rougis pas totalement
d'être son arrière petite fille il est
le seul écrivain au monde à avoir écrit
un roman de science-fiction catholique
c'est à dire que ça s'appelle la
rédemption de mars c'est l'histoire d'un
missionnaire qui prend une fusée pour
aller sur la planète mars dans l'idée
d'évangéliser les martiens ont été bien
allumer votre grand père c'est qu'ils
magnifique ce qu'il n'y parvient pas il
voilà grand-père était torturé par la
chair et son missionnaire qui va sur la
planète mars c'est qu'on ne va pas d'une
très belle martienne et se termine par
une scène d'amour entre le missionnaire
et la belle dans cette famille
l'imagination alors bon vous êtes né au
japon vous effectuez on n'était pas au
courant de tout ça de ce fait n'a kobe
votre père était ambassadeur votre père
c'est quelqu'un mais c'est quand même le
seul européen qui sait chanter le no
c'est la seule non japonais au monde à
chanter professionnellement le novice et
les pousses messieurs c'est une famille
graeff alors là bon toute votre enfance
c'était un peu bringuebalé 1 comme les
enfants l'ambassadeur vous déménagez
tous les trois ans en chine au laos
birmanie bangladesh ayant la seule chose
finalement que vous retrouvez de
d'escale en escale c'est un peu la
bibliothèque de vos parents quoi c'est
ça on sait à dax allemand comme si on
lis mes livres on pourrait se dire avec
l'enfance qu'elle a eu ça va être des
romands
se sont rencontrés à diamants très axé
sur le langage parce que très vite fait
remarquer que j'ai compris que la seule
identité que j'avais à travers tous les
déracinements c'était le langage vous
avez lu les mais les misérables est à
l'âge de 9 ans quand même y avait une
part de pause dans tout ça oui je
voulais poser à 9 ans alors vous vous ai
commencé à écrire très jeune hygiène de
l'assassin qui le premier bouquin publié
en france en fait été je crois le le
dixième le 11e le 11 le 11e alors bon
vous écrivez ce bouquin vous l'envoyer
par la poste oui vous l'envoyer chez
deux éditeur chez gallimard et chez
albin michel henry alors sollers vous
réponds je n'aime pas les canulars oui
bon là il a perdu une affaire là mais
moi je suis je remercie très
chaleureusement sollers parce que je
suis tellement contente d'être chez
albin michel quand même grâce à lui quoi
oui bah oui finalement oui mais là il
doit se mordre les doigts quand ils vous
croiser dans les cocktails vous vendez
beaucoup de livres maintenant non oui
mais il affecte de ne pas me répète mais
tout va très bien a bon goût salaire ça
se fait pas alors bon alors hygiène de
l'assassin donc sorti en 92 après on est
sorti un parent il ya eu le sabotage
amoureux dont qui est la pièce avec
valérie mairesse aux orane là en ce
moment les combustibles en 94 les
catilinaires en 95 il est alors prêt ya
attentats en 97 et mercure en croatie
eyal inquiète oublié dans votre
biographie hameau de bibliographie qui
est transmise par albin michel donc
c'est pas s'est pas tapé c'est péplum
qu'elles n'ont pas pas pour soi mais n'y
parvient pas j'en sais rien vous venez
de m'apprendre bien parce qu'à l'époque
la critique avait dit que c'était bavard
et interminable mais la critique a dit à
mon sujet tout et son contraire je peux
vous retrouver pour n'importe quel de
mes livres autant de partisans que des
tracts dans les blogs c'est pas vous qui
leur avait dit le mettais plus
d'aliments bio pas moi j'aurais connais
tous les enfants très bien que ça fait
oui ça en fait un paquet d'avants alors
êtes vous avez beaucoup de succès non
seulement en france mais dans d'autres
pays du g 13 buts en 18 langues 18
langues et en allemagne depuis le grand
prix des libraires bien de dire que
c'est un succès populaire passe et pas
seulement ça s'annonce bien alors vous
avez écrite contre 40 bouquin 7 publié
mais je suis en train d'écrire le 36e
s'affoler graphomane kouassi de maladie
que vous avez c'est un peu une maladie
mais c'est une maladie qui me fait jouer
donc je suis très content bah oui ça
c'est les meilleurs maladie alors vous
pouvez très branché chiffre à vous dites
je fais partie des 1 % d'écrivains qui
vivent de ce qu'ils écrivent ou dit
j'écris 3,7 manuscrit par an je suis
fasciné par les filles voilées jamais
rien compris donc ça me fascine alors
vous dites j'assiste à votre propre
fécondité avec beaucoup de passivité
vous dites j'écris quatre heures par
jour sinon je suis dangereuse alors il
ya une phrase qui est terrible dans ce
que vous dites si vous dites le matin
j'ai besoin d'être traite de la vache je
sais c'est monstrueux mais je trouve ça
moi même assez répugnant ce besoin
d'écrire vous trouvez sur la culture
aussi mais qu'est ce que vous pouvez
rien n'est sûr
c'est un
peu monstrueux entre c'est complètement
attendez vous allez être très en forme
et tout mais comme disait beckett vous
êtes bons qu'à ce à quoi sert un certain
alors je pose des problèmes parce que si
vous continuez à sortir un livre par an
on n'est pas l'abri d'avoir à la fin
comme ça 60 sont divisés aucun projet
d'avenir je n'ai jamais voulu continuer
à publier tous les ans un livre je n'en
sais rien 70 99 oui après j'en sais rien
d'accord je ne vois jamais me dérange
pas mais en fait c'est vrai que ça fait
quand même à la sortie ça fera 60
bouquin c'est pas très grave parce que
c'est des tout-petits libre ouais plus
ce que vous publiez pas plus les
innombrables est-ce que vous avez pas
peur vous il est vraiment en écriture
comme on dit est ce que pas peur de
décrire sans vivre parce que non j'ai
une vie amoureuse très intense qui me
rattache beaucoup à la ben oui alors
vous êtes toujours eu le désir d'un peu
et c'est pour ça que vous êtes devenu
une vedette aussi bien évidemment un peu
des pâtés de briller dès votre plus
jeune âge non détrompez vous gé
on peut dire que dès l'âge de 10 ans à
l'âge de 20 ans j'ai été totalement seul
ah oui s'il n'y avait pas eu ma soeur
qui est pour moi un personnage essentiel
il y aurait donc là c'est un peu une
revanche là c'est pas ça je n'avais
sincèrement jamais songé à la moindre
espèce de célébrités en revanche ce qui
est certain c'est qu'à l'âge de 23 ans
j'ai pensé à gagner ma vie par sa mère
d'accord quand vous êtes vous avez des
112 effet une des sensations du fuji
yama vous avez descendu en 40 minutes
3776 mettre ses biens sans faire
remarquer ça quand même non non l'ex
place par sport vous avez ainsi un
record en plus c'est un battant un
record mondial mais l'exploit sportif
est toujours une chose qui m'a fasciné
salander dit vous allez quand même vous
êtes comme exhibitionniste vous exhibez
votre pathologie mais vous ne savez pas
ce que je n'existe pas ce qui fait que
finalement pas exhibitionniste vous dit
tout mais pour les télé ça vous êtes une
bonne cliente pas ce que vous dites
quand j'étais petit j'étais anorexique
c'était un refus de rentrer dans le mode
de me demander adultes vous dit dès la
puberté l'existence n'est qu'un épilogue
ce n'est pas très gai vous étiez un peu
alcoolique parce que vous finissiez les
coupes de champagne à l'ambassade à
l'automatique c'est pas très médiatique
non c'est pas médiatiquement fait cette
accumulation comme ça de et alors vous
êtes et médiatique en revanche vous êtes
pourrite ofaj quoi c'est à dire que vous
mangez du dd des fruits blé dur up ford
est un peu pourri je ne vois toujours
pas ce que ceci a nui diatigui pas si ça
vous rend intéressante par rapport à
tous les autres qui mange pas des trucs
pourris mais je trouve que c'est un
petit peu triste de s'intéresser à moi
pour ces raisons là je pense que mes
livres sont de meilleures raisons pour
s'intéresser à moi t'intéresse a valu ne
pas parler de la pourriture si ça amuse
les gens oui mais personnellement je
sais simplement mon alimentation je ne
trouve pas si intéressant mais quand
vous donne on vous demande votre bille
vous dites vomir
disons que c'est une chose qui m'arrive
souvent en écrivant ouais vous avez pas
peur effectivement qu'on parle plus de 2
to sac de vos bouquins dont je vais vous
dire d'une certaine façon même si je
trouve ça tout à fait lamentable
d'une certaine façon ça m'arrange bien
j'écris dans l'hygiène de l'assassin que
parler d'un livre n'avait aucun sens je
vous remercie tu as pensé que par les
commerçants il faut le lire alors plutôt
que vous expliquez vous voyez mon ivre
est très profond parce que je vomis et
puis c'est très bien mais c'est très
bien voilà ce que vous êtes très
particulière merci a bientot on se
connaissait pas comme ça maintenant se
connaît et puis vous viendrez en
septembre 99 alors pour le pour le
suivant vous savez le titre déjà oui
mais je ne dis jamais elle avance à pas
de chance à bientôt j'accueille
maintenant amélie nothomb à
mais bravo pour la manade loïc on voit
qu'ils ont l'habitude sur les bateaux
atteint mais comment une aboul jay là et
il m'a attaché la la la il prendrait
alors à mettre ici donc c'est très très
déçu parce que vous avez pas de chapeau
pourquoi tu as des mitaines ah mais ça
c'est très beau c'est le
porte-jarretelles de la main
j'allais
en sont l'auteur tout de suite alors
votre actualité
les combustibles reprise à partir du 25
mars au studio des champs elysées pour
60 représentations angers en vitesse les
condisciples cd livres en fête oui j'ai
des gens qui n'ont plus d'autre façon de
ne pas mourir que de brûler les livres
deuxième actualité justement là je vais
montrer attention vous êtes près les
enfants
voilà stupeur et tremblements ans chez
albin michel grand prix de l'académie
française un gros gros gros succès est
en fait comme vous le savez françois
sextuplé tremblement de c'est une façon
de s'adresser à l'empereur du japon et
c'est une parabole d'une certaine façon
pour parler de l'entreprise qui au japon
et d y fier c'est ça oui c'est une
histoire vraie c'est votre histoire
c'est dans une multinationale au japon
oui mais vous avez vous raconter dans ce
bouquin tous comment ça se passe c'est
l'histoire d'une d'une chute sociale
vertigineuse qui se termine qui se
termine aux chiottes voilà
c'est vrai là c'est absolument vrai oui
alors sur un peu autobiographique passé
beaucoup ta biographie que c'est lié au
japon vous êtes né à kobe votre père
était ambassadeur de belgique le jour et
chanteurs de nous la nuit c'est toujours
vrai ou toujours vrai c'est comment le
nous fait me voir un peu je vais être
défigurée par votre faute parce que
dites vous bien que rien ne prédispose à
posséder l'organe qu'il faut donc je
vais devoir le chercher à des endroits
précis indicible
what you want ont fui yoro bi ton
chironi des sous
ou
alors ce qui veut dire ce qui veut dire
c'est que quand amélie nothomb mettait
petit
pendant cette dure trois plans vous avez
très en quatre heures la suisse 30
secondes et alors ils étaient obligés de
l'approché des missions et les étiages
nous tiens pas de père vous aimait
c'était pire pour lui parce que lui
chantait à genoux lui et chanter un jour
vous écoutiez à genoux comme ça mais oui
oui qu'est ce que ça veut dire ce que tu
viens de te faire n'ont envie de tout
amateur et c'est un jeu de mots débile
mais non mais non c'est du jamais j'ai
remarqué que c'était un jeu de mot
est lâché et qui t'a fait est ce que
c'est parce qu'il était très content
ratés comme ça qu'elle disait du chic
c'est un rapport avec le wii wheel
bouquin se passe au japon j'ai eu du mal
a trouvé ça joli jeu mais je comprends
que plus je n'ai pas la culture qui font
vraiment un autre type de champ
certaines âmes ses pensées d'accord j'ai
vu dans l'oeil des limites si nous
sommes regardés on est
alors vous avez une enfance finalement
malgré des plombes entières passées à
genoux à écouter votre père chantait
d'une ou une enfance assez heureuse ah
oui et vous dites que souvent l'enfance
malheureuse est utilisé en matière de
criminalité comme une circonstance
atténuante et finalement l'enfance
heureuse devrait l'être aussi parce que
d'une certaine façon vous êtes vous
depuis abonnés un nostalgie vous avez
dit très triste oui il faut maintiendra
beaucoup on vous plains beaucoup alors
quand vous étiez au japon nous était de
l'objet de racisme je savais que les
petits garçons les pythies vous
déshabiller pour ce métier blanche
parler c'est à dire que j'allais au
jardin d'enfants japonais et j'étais la
seule non japonaises de mon jardin
d'enfants et un jour on m'a retrouvé
dans la cour de récréation en dessous de
tous les autres enfants qui m'avait
déshabiller en effet pouvoir si j'étais
blanche partout ils sont sympas les
petits chocolats et
blanche par théo oui alors donc ça
c'était la bonne époque c'était le japon
après ça comment ça partait en chine en
lacets c'est terrible parce que vous
êtes gardé par des soldats si vous
parlez à des gens à prendre leurs voix
puis jamais puisqu'il faut pas parler
aux étrangers c'est un cas ça dans
laquelle 72 à 75 donc c'est encore le
maoïsme voilà et le père d'amélie donc
été ambassadeur de belgique donc il dit
après on est allé au laos en birmanie et
au bangladesh
et vous dites très bien et on comprend
très bien ce que vous avez vécu vous dit
ma seule identité c'était le langage est
mon seul repère la bibliothèque de mes
parents c'est la seule chose c'est la
seule chose que je ne perdais pas tous
les trois ans voilà oui alors à 9 ans
vous lisiez déjà les misérables un peu
pour la galerie qu'enfin vous le faisiez
quand même oui oui vous avez lu la bible
aussi à ces jeunes je les trouvais ça
très sexuel écouter l'ancien testament
regorge d'allusions sexuelles est bon
quand j'étais petit je les comprenais
pas vraiment mais je comprenais que
c'était louche quoi je faisais une liste
et une phrase d'ailleurs c'est une forme
iqra pas avec la nièce de ton beau frère
mais c'est dans les temps le srec ticket
dans le poteau la nomme il ya des
règlements sexuelle d'une précision d'un
ghetto c'est inquiétant parce que ça
veut dire qu'ils avaient vraiment penser
à chaque cas donc c'est vraiment été
écrit par des gens très excités par les
obsédés oui alors après tout ça à vous
retourner en belgique vous découvrez
votre grand mère qui était assez
méchante avec vous elle vous dit
j'espère que tu es intelligente parce
que tu es tellement laide c'est la
première chose qu'elle paie dit en effet
à savoir ce qu'il fait mais c'est
formidable parce que suite à ça toutes
les vacheries que des critiques mais je
me dis c'est rien du tout donc les dix
pas tellement de vacheries amélien vous
êtes plutôt si pas tellement à peindre
des sorties de ce côté là sûrement pas
ça marche très bien pour vous et vous
découvrez à ce moment là que votre père
ne tombe c'est votre grand père grand
père pierre ne tombe romancier assez
connue en belgique je vais famille
notons qu'une famille importante en
belgique la belgique d'expliquer quand
la belgique s'est constitué dans les
centres en récupère du monde c'est une
14e place à du vent parce que je pense
pas que les gens ben ali qui nous
regardent mais s'il l'est c'est quand la
belgique s'est constitué en 1830 chaque
famille a porté une partie de la
belgique et la famille ne tombe à
apporter le l'extrême sud-est et
luxembourg page voilà luxembourg belge
en que chacun apporté et il ya un holà
la constitution belge a été écrite par
un ne tombent entre autres et donc votre
grand-père donc le temps avait fondé la
mouvance et des actions d'axa qui était
un petit peu comme l'action française et
quand vous disiez maintenant à
l'université des gens faisaient la
gueule que vous saviez pas vous mais
c'est vrai que j'étais pas du tout au
courant et que je lis a pris un peu tard
oui quoi et donc là vous décidé de
retourner au japon oui parce que pour
moi c'était mon pays ou y voilà et vous
devenez amoureuse folle
du fils du plus gros joaillier japonais
voilà à morestel c'est beaucoup dire
mais enfin c'est un bon souvenir aulas
et
c'est vrai qu'à l'époque j'étais
couverte de bijoux sans sapin de noël
est donc comme je lé plaquer finalement
sept jours avant la date prévue pour le
mariage dans un mouvement parfaitement
stupide je lui ai rendu tous les bijoux
j'ai jamais
dit à un moment il vaut mieux jouer
l'étranger débile parce que je croise
supérieurs à nous en fait
leur humilité leur politesse cache le
plus souvent un complexe de supériorité
assez phénoménal en effet et c'est vrai
que si on si on se fait passer pour
l'étranger débile alors on est on est
triste mais à partir du moment où on
montre qu'on connaît leur langue et ça
tombe bien ça commence à aller bon ça
doit bien et alors là bon on la fait
courte vous écrivez votre premier
manuscrit c'est-à-dire hygiène de
l'assassin vous l'envoyez à deux vous
l'envoyez à deux maisons d'édition
gallimard et albin michel et gallimard
incroyablement philippe sollers refuse
le manuscrit d'avellino tombe en disant
j'aime pas les canulars et c'est vrai
qu'à l'époque le bruit avait couru je
m'en souviens que c'est pas vous qui
l'aviez écrit on n'a pas envie et c'est
un homme âgé un homme cultivé qui a
écrit ça c'est bazens et tournier c'est
jacques laurent et ça en dit long sur
l'idée que les gens se font des jeunes
jeu
arrêtez
donc de vous arrêter
en plus c'est dégueulasse qui sera
possédée j'aurais
continué je vous fais attention
c'est la punition c'est mon si vous êtes
chez albin michel j'étais contente
d'être amis chères invitées et remercie
beaucoup salaires qui convainc croisé
sollers et qui sait vous vendez
énormément deux événements bukavu est
traduite dans 20 pays et ses énormes
succès quand vous croisez solaire ce
qu'est ce qu'est ce qui vous dit il a
fait que ceux de me confondre avec les
attachés de presse
alors c'était votre premier l'hygiène de
l'assassin c'est votre premier roman il
est le sien publiés vous aviez déjà
écrit c'est en fait votre 11e manuscrits
vous avez qui 36 bouquin oui je suis en
train d'écrire le 37e et vous écrivez
trois bouquins par en trois sets pour
être exact
alors vous ne publiez pas toucher à la
publication c'est à peu près un accident
dans ce que j'écris puisque oui il y en
a huit qui sont publiées sur 37 spéciale
alors vous dites que c'est une situation
pathologique incontrôlée du sud la graph
oman il n'y a pas d'autre mot non mais
pourquoi ferais-je autre chose alors que
ça me procure un ch'ti grand plaisir we
would it c'est une maladie qui me fait
jouer exactement alors pourquoi
dirais-je oui c'est pour ça vous n'êtes
jamais fait psychanalyse et d'ailleurs
non non non non c'est mon gagne pain
tout ça envie d'un truc est pas très
féminin quand même je sais pas si je
vais le dire vous savez je suis très
discret comme mec moi qu'est ce qui fait
tiquer bah je sais pas si je vais parler
vous dis je suis comme les vaches en
parlant de l'écriture je suis comme les
vaches j'ai besoin d'être traite tous
les matins maintenant je suis d'accord
ça me fait tenir salon franchement accès
c'est horrible vont arrêter de dire ça
c'est horrible mais le problème c'est
que c'est vrai allez loïc allez vous
une bonne marmande du japon
vous aimez problème quand même
sérieusement que j'ai quand même un
certain nombre de problèmes
psychologiques parce que par exemple
vous flashez sur les gens les mais pas
uniquement massy mais aussi des fois
vous avez rencontré un mec les dans un
bus et vous avez envie d'aller le
féliciter pour son originalité de son
interprétation d'aller déjà lance en
effet que certaines personnes mériterait
d'être félicités pour leur aplomb dans
la laideur moi c'est vrai mais vous
voyez un homme les vous dites je rêve
d'être dans les bras de cette guerre
vivante
et fissa dans un de mes bouquins là vous
l'avez écrit vous l'avez jamais vu
en revanche vous mangez de la pourriture
végétal fabuleux ça c'est très joli et
j'ai très bon vous êtes pourrite ofaj en
fait oui c'est à dire c'est à dire en
janvier google quand vous mangez quoi
quand je voulais c'est pour les aliments
quand je me nourris moi même
apéro le seigneur avec tout le temps
mais c'est vrai j'ai région rabat salé
justement que j'allais parler de
conservation alors je m'interroge et au
pourri pour des raisons gustatives parce
que je trouve ça s'était attaché à de la
salle arts et des loisirs
j'achète des des fruits je les oublie et
si six semaines plus tard il commence à
devenir bon ben oui parce que là on les
oublie pas l odeur on est on les
retrouve mais j'ai une salle prévue pour
pour ça c'est vrai ça des tonneaux
histoire et est-ce qu'on peut
éventuellement t'envoyer des aliments
avec tout ce qui manque au lmmc
cdu verts de gris la pourrit autour et
justement le vert de gris c'est le
meilleur en plus c'est très joli et des
poils vers jamais malade non parce que
j'ai à force d'avoir avalé toutes les
maladies possibles et imaginables je les
appelle des civils c'est un champignon
mais ccc mitchell
sait quand elle monte une pomme fraîche
que la lave
linge ou non j'étais foutu la résidence
la fin des marchés c'est dans les
marchés ya des gens qui viennent mais
c'est tout à fait vrai je vis souvent un
moment terrible dans ma vie c'est quand
je passe sur les marchés qu'on s'est
finie et qui a les trucs qui traînent là
je sens encore un combat entre ma
dignité humaine et mes bas instincts
parce que je vois des vieilles grappes
de raisin qui traînent par terre j'ai
envie de me jeter dessus même qu'un
doublement mais les gens vont me
regarder c'est pas possible je peux pas
faire ça et rosés suisses vous faire
vomir je ne savais pas si simple que ça
je ne joue pas du tout un peu à venir
c'est pas ça
pour écrire pour elle peut atteindre
l'état mental nécessaire pour que
j'écrive
je dois même administré à joël matin un
demi-litre de thé beaucoup trop fort et
se tait moment malades bon voilà la
réaction normale dès le vomissement
alors tranquille c'est par millions que
c'est pas du tout à un bis mais c'est
plus calme et de ne pas monter des
techniques extraordinaires pour
m'empêcher de venir avant à partir d'un
certain moment j'ai le droit mais pas
tout de suite est ce que vous avez
toujours le sentiment qu'il ya quelqu'un
d'autre vous êtes deux à l'intérieur de
votre corps et que vous avez cet ennemi
mais sincèrement j'ai l'impression que
ce n'est pas quelque chose de tellement
personnel oui en effet j'ai un sacré
ennemis en moi mais j'ai l'impression
connectons des nombreux à pouvoir le
dire non vous connaissez le portrait
chinois si tu étais une fleur si tu
étais un voilà là je vais vous faire une
lentille portrait chinois
[Applaudissements]
mais je suis calme bouge pas avant le
seigneur
si vous étiez donc si vous étiez une
injure vous seriez quoi comme injures
[__] ciel [__] siège s'est très si
vous étiez une maladie
le syndrome d'alzheimer plate que tu une
maladie que j'ai inventé dans un canal -
assurer 3 étaient comme creutzfeldt
jacob ou non non non si vous étiez un
accident mon passage dans cette émission
si vous étiez une perversion l'écriture
si vous étiez une guerre
l'invasion du japon par la belgique
si vous étiez un microbe la listeria
parce que depuis le temps à la listeria
c'est moi si vous étiez un dictateur un
dictateur éclairé un vice
le vinaigre
une arme la fourche est un supplice
la gourmette ses propos m brumath wii
commence à porter une gourmette oui si
vous étiez une panne
balaj et une panne quoi si vous étiez
une cicatrice
celle que j'ai là si vous étiez une
[__] l'une des 343 si vous étiez un
poison le mercure une torture
le saumon
une humiliation
le serre-tête un assassin mois un
détritus ce que je mange si vous étiez
une chanteuse robert baer
et quand robert ballard aubers don qui
est un chanteur qui s'appelle catherine
une chanteuse qui s'appelle robert
maintenant d'ailleurs j'ai un petit
morceau de catherine mais je suis dans
ma mère et je vous emmerde
voilà maintenant je vais mettre un petit
morceau de robert
o o
c'est roberto
c'est robert c'est une amie avoue 1
d'ailleurs vous dites je place la
musique plus haut que la littérature
vous auriez m robert
moi je sis j'écris parce que je sais pas
chanter pour moi je n'ai pas composé de
musique mais je place en effet la
musique bien plus haut que la
littérature c'est clair cela pas besoin
d'être traduit la musique celle avantage
aucun besoin d'être traduit l'effet
beaucoup plus fort plus direct oui oui
je suis d'accord j'aimerais être
parolière broc vous avez dit comme je
n'ai vraiment aucune chance dans la
musique franchement j'ai aucune
disposition d'aucune sorte j'essaie
quand même de danse glissé mon pied dans
la porte vous est fait là bas c'est
possible vous avez fait les paroles d'un
des morceaux de robert absolument et ça
s'appelle l'appel de la succube voilà la
succube vous pouvez expliquer pour nos
amis mais si une succube c'est un donc
un esprit femelle qui vient tenter
vivant pendant leur sommeil voilà rien q
c'est quoi c'est le malade c'est ça
c'est le mari de la succube c'est le
mari la soutient voilà l'appel de là ces
cubes donc par chanté par robert et
paroles d'amélie nothomb
[Musique]
voilà vous êtes très copines toutes les
deux noms oui un
non c'est vrai oui bien si je l'entends
et je vous entends rien à y gagner
non mais en effet l'amitié à quelque
chose d'extrêmement important pour moi
et ça tombe bien
alors il ya une chance sur l'un des
titres sont un peu je dirais ne tombe
bien en place et aux logiques il y en a
qui s'appelle triste et sale lorient n'a
ses natures mortes et alors vous faites
à une chanson qui s'appelle colchiques
mon amour et est en fait vous parler du
sida dans cette chanson oui alors je
vais demander pourquoi tiens on va faire
un quiz est ce que vous savez pourquoi
donc la chanson seule chic mon amour
parle du sida parce que ça parle du sida
est ce que quelqu'un sait ici un rapport
avec la lancer un portail m'a fait je
suis même ressemble à une colchiques
oui vous avez vous voulez vous
alors là colchiques peu dans la
pharmacopée ou la pharmacie tout court
je ne sais c'est un poison voilà ça fait
trois ans c'est bien c'est à présent et
c'est bien c'est un poisson mais les
colchiques peut tuer une vache oui et
surtout une colle fixe d'abord une fleur
qui est très très belle et l'amour c'est
six superbes aussi savoir que ça peut
amener à l'image c'est bien robert s'est
très vite et très bien où va très très
bien alors le premier métier on va
constituer petite fille est chanteuse
non je suis dit
qu'est ce que tu t'es déjà fait dix ans
de piano classique que vous avez fait de
la danse expérience et surtout nathan si
vous avez fait un grand tour pour
revenir finalement à la chanson voilà
j'ai fait même que quelques films et
quelques quelques téléfilms et puis un
jour en écoutant marcia baila par rita
mitsouko vous avez compris que pouvait
faire autre chose dans la vie que
d'attendre un coup de fil exactement si
vous avez décidé de créer notre univers
de catherine ringer danse divinement
bien donc c'était une fois de plus la
danse qui m'avait attiré et comme
j'avais toujours écrit
je me suis dit qu'il fallait que je
trouve un musicien ouais j'ai trouvé un
musicien il s'appelle français
vous êtes copine tout le monde voit des
allusions vous avez quand même déclaré
robert est vraiment une partie de moi
oui mais je en
amitié je ne me paraît pas du tout
inconcevable enfin non non plus nous
avons quand même j'explique pourquoi je
j'affirme et ça aussi fort
je sais pas moi je me suis choqué par
aucune de vos paroles je vous trouve
charmant et bien côté robert merci donc
je leur montre votre album une dernière
fois ce qui se passe
voilà et pour être sûr de ne rien rater
de linda hardy tube abonnez vous je
m'étais un peu ce bleu